also here tonight louisiana senator john
kennedy
i mean senator kennedy first they don't
want you to go to prison and then when
you do go to prison for a heinous crime
they want to make it as cushy and as
favorable as possible
why do you think they want to do that
because they're woke
with respect to crime
i would rather be
forced to to listen to o.j jokes for the
rest of eternity than to take the advice
of president biden
or governor newsom
they're both nauseously woke
and one of the cardinal tenets of wokism
is that the criminal is the victim
the victim isn't the victim
the criminal is the victim
wokers believe that
no one should have to accept
responsibility
they believe that it's always someone
else's fault
and their motto is
hear no evil see no evil prosecute no
evil
now fortunately
most americans it at least those who
have
the iq
above a sloth understand that's not the
way the real world works
uh most americans understand
that unfortunately and for whatever
reason there are some people in our
society jesse who are not sick
they're not confused they're not mixed
up it's not that their mama or daddy
didn't love them enough they're just bad
or at least they do very bad things
and that's why we have to have prisons
and with respect to those people who say
oh my gosh i'm in prison isn't this
terrible
i would say look
if you don't want to go to prison
don't do illegal stuff
but the corollary to that is
what you allow is what will continue
and if you do
do really bad stuff
we have to send folks like that
anti-society to prison otherwise
you're just going to get more of the
same
and unfortunately i hate i'm sorry to
have to say it but both president biden
and governor newsom
have adopted this jaundiced
view of
reality when you're at the
senate cafeteria and you guys are
drinking the little milks you know or
you peel it open like that and you're
maybe sitting around the table gossiping
with some colleagues from the other side
of the aisle
do you sense that some of your
democratic colleagues are getting
the anger that's erupting across the
country about this out of control crime
or is it just kind of going in one ear
and out the other no i think they get it
they do then why aren't they doing
anything about it
or seeing anything there are a variety
of reasons some of my i think some of my
democratic colleagues well of course
some of my democratic colleagues as is
their right but some of them are woke
yeah other others are scared of the
wokers others don't want to cross
president biden
um
they started
uh that well they didn't
some of the wokers started the defund
and disrespect the police movement
they tolerated it
president biden allowed it to happen
and
you see the result it's safer to walk
down the streets of mogadishu than it is
to walk down the streets of new york
and i've said this before
chicago
and and to some extent my city in new
orlea in louisiana new orleans that i
love to death they've become
the world's largest outdoor shooting
ranges
what you allow is what will continue and
as long as we allow this
the criminals are not going to be
unhappy with this and they're going to
keep committing crimes
it's common sense but you're exactly
right senator kennedy thank you so much
for joining prime time thank you jesse
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else